the BLM documentary that you did the
biggest liver sold
phenomenal when you did that and you're
kind of going through how you know you
know from one lens I'm kind of watching
you right now because I'm watching it as
a Talent as an individual to see what
evolution you're you're personally going
through right like hey as you change and
your life changes and you're making
money and you have kids and you get
married and you move you've also I used
to be interested I'm really not
interested that's not my passion that's
not my fight this is not my fault I'm
interested and then now you're going
into True Crime you know with the this
this recent one that you did which is uh
uh what's his name Steve Avery Stephen
Avery yeah and what happened with that
so out of all the topics you could have
chosen to do documentary on why this
it's actually a perfect build on
destroying the BLM narrative and it's a
perfect build on who I am and how I got
into this place we started this
conversation by talking about you know
Trump coming down and me not wanting him
to be there and then me realizing that I
was a victim of propaganda my entire
life and so as a cultural Warrior if
that's what you want to call me
um I I am really focused on getting
people to understand that their entire
life could potentially being decided
upon by Propaganda by propagandist
effort that what they think they know
they don't know and so obviously the
huge tackle in the political climate of
black lives matter was really how I
started myself in politics as it was
like unheard of a black person not
supporting BLM how could you not and
then I needed to show people you know
after the dust had settled this is what
I was saying and now black lives BLM as
an organization is bankrupt and people
watched my documentary they saw where
the money went they realized that they
had been duped because they were
emotional and they were made to feel
guilty because they were white and they
just sent money into a dark hole and
this next documentary is really the same
exact Examination for whatever reason we
set our presets to trusting a
documentary more than the news like
we're like well now I'm getting the real
information because it's a documentary
and there's no way that these two
lesbians from New York who created
making a murderer could possibly be
playing with me
um they must be telling the truth the
villain the villain is actually the hero
in this docu-series super important
first Endeavor really that Netflix made
into docu-series and it largely built
their empire I would say on this story
and Netflix has since continued this
tradition of taking villains and
convincing the public that they're
Heroes the Central Park five guilty as
Sin guilty as Sin and yet a Netflix
documentary has made people believe that
they're not guilty of sin uh they've
softened Jeffrey Dahmer you know this is
Netflix's Legacy right this is they what
what are we doing as a culture it's not
just happening
um in the real world you know we're also
seeing aspects of that in the
Fantastical world uh Maleficent you know
forget that story what about actually
she's a person in there Joker he's
actually a human being right we take
these villains and we turn them into
hero and we're facing this cultural
assimilation where people want to
believe that actually the villain has a
heart and so I wanted to dive into the
Steven Avery story because I was stunned
as I when I when I learned the truth
about what happened but there's a larger
thing that I'm trying to express to
people about mainstream media about
Netflix right the power of Netflix is it
is an absolute Powerhouse and it is
forming the way that people think and
this story is kind of where it began and
I thought it was interesting challenge
for me because it wasn't split a lot on
political lines I wanted to do something
that felt a little more apolitical
because it wasn't like conservatives
thought he was guilty and liberals
thought that he was innocent no
conservatives and liberals alike got
duped by this documentary and Netflix
banked and um it's just it's a very
compelling story but the the truer story
is the study of humanity the study of of
propaganda the psychology of propaganda
which I am forever fascinated about
yeah this is I mean when I was watching
it you couldn't stop you're just curious
to know what happened with it did you
follow this I was I was watching it
because and going off your point Candace
so 19 what Netflix when they first aired
the first episode 19 point something
million watching it people like would
not go on dates they wouldn't go with
the friends they would speed home and go
do it so so Candace you're painting a
different picture to where and I saw the
the one of the females that that started
it she went to school she wanted to be a
director and a writer and everything and
then she was just like she read the
story on a train right she read in a
newspaper and she was like I'm gonna go
in there I'm gonna go to Wisconsin where
it was in Wisconsin right yeah and just
flip the script and make it something
that people would want to watch so it's
all it's all Bs yeah and and to see
people like conservatives that I've had
on the show that were like I thought
that he wasn't guilty you know it's
really yeah they were good they did a
very good job at making you think that
these people actually are victims and
also can we talk about the why it really
matters me do this in the real world and
you're not doing in on a Disney movie is
because because a woman at the who was
victimized by Stephen Avery he was
eventually convicted she was raped by
two men she was shot she was stabbed she
was cut up into pieces and she was
burned in a burn pin she was 22 years
old had her entire life ahead of her and
because of people like Alec Baldwin and
Trevor Noah in a mainstream media effort
and this anti-policing sentiment and
this belief that we have that the
villains could actually be the ones that
are struggling her family then not only
had to bury her this faithful Catholic
Family who handled this in just the most
wonderful capacity given the
circumstances then had to deal with
conspiracy theories because Alec Baldwin
said well her brother wasn't crying
enough so you know so that's part of it
that means that like actually Steven
Avery is innocent so you just imagine
what we do to real people when we recast
the victims as the villains and the
villains as the victims There's real
life consequences to that I I think this
is a media thing that goes on and I was
particularly incense I remember if
anybody remembers when Rolling Stone
magazine two weeks after the capture of
the Boston Marathon bomber remember
there were two brothers yeah and one
actually ran over his brother during the
case and killed him and then he was on
the cover of Rolling Stone they were
fawning over him as this attractive guy
who just didn't understand there it is
there it is you know and they portrayed
him as this because they actually
rolling someone won't tell you is they
actually liked the fact that he took
action against what was core America
yeah they actually liked the fact that
he had actually stepped out to do it
there was an undercurrent here where
they were not only making a hero he was
the resistance against the U.S you know
establishment that they wanted to see
and that's that's the convicting
murderer it's the same thing in 2015 the
anti-police sentiment was building so
the reason why Trevor Noah and Alec
Baldwin and all these Hollywood
characters were were jumping on this
wasn't for the same reason people at
home were watching it was because
because this was this was the message
that was coming down the pipeline now
all of a sudden we want anti-police the
police are the bad guys the police are
crooked this is the new American shtick
so to speak I have a question you
brought up conspiracy theorists
um this doesn't necessarily have to do
with documentary but it kind of does
because it's on daily wire so in your
most recent episode of Candace Owens you
you kind of threw some shade on the
conspiracy theorists you kind of even
all the right wing and you're like on
one hand you know I'm a anti-semitic
Kanye supporter but on the other hand
I'm a puppet of Israel of Israel and Ben
Shapiro yeah so which one is it
matter people that's so far into their
conspiracy theories the stuff that I
have read about myself it's insane like
literally if you don't place your hands
right even when I'm wearing a t-shirt on
my show yeah t-shirt on my show they'll
be like uh what does it mean I'm like I
don't know it's a plane they're like
okay but like what does it mean why is
there an orange and a Concord plane and
I'm like oh I don't know they're like
well because you know people on the
internet will just make something up
it's true literally I have to be
conscious of what I wear I be conscious
of my hand placements they'll say that
I'm in the Illuminati there are
conspiracy theories about my
father-in-law who sits in the House of
Lords in the UK that he plucked me works
for the Rothschilds at my marriage to
Sham I mean people I get it I get it we
I get why we don't trust the media and
that's good but there there's also a
level that people will go to trick to
create conspiracy theories and when you
watch committing a murderer and we show
you the fandom the fact that this sick
disgusting man with a history of incest
and pedophilia and you know uh being
violent towards women is is getting
fiance is writing him letters and he has
fiances in prison and people that are in
love with him and crying outside yeah we
gotta talk about that we gotta talk
about it he does look like Brad Pitt I
mean obviously he doesn't I'm being
sarcastic so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]